-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
And this is "Late Night,"
and it's Wednesday.
Let's get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
The Manhattan district attorne
has reportedly convened
a grand jury
that is expected to decide
whether to indict
former President Trump.
God, imagine that arrest.
"You have
the right to an attorney.
But, as a friend,
I wouldn't recommend it."
Former President Trump sai
in his website today
that his administration
is the reason
for low coronavirus cases
and successful vaccine rollout
in the U.S.,
which is sort of like
the captain of the Hindenbur
saying,
"Don't forget who got us
off the ground."
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
is facing criticism
after tweeting
that coronavirus
vaccine passports
and mask mandates
are just like
Nazis forcing Jewish peopl
to wear a gold star.
It's the first time she's wanted
people to be undocumented.
A junior high principal in
Arkansas apologized recently
after the school's yearboo
featured a photo
of former President Donald Trump
with the caption,
"President Trump
was not impeached."
He also apologized for the claim
that Trump was too sweet
to be forgotten.
According to a new study,
researchers believe
that the maximum age
a human could physically reach
is 150 years old.
"Challenge accepted,"
said the U.S. Senate.
Former baseball player
Alex Rodriguez
recently launched a line
of concealer for men,
and then men tried
to put it on wedding rings
[ Laughter ]
I tried -- I tried to do the -
deliver it
the way I feel Jenny
would have wanted me to.
[ Laughter ]
"And then men..."
According to a new study,
relocating wolves
to areas with
frequent car accidents
caused by deer
can reduce collisions by 24%
which almost makes up
for the 3,000% increase
in wolf attacks.
[ Laughter ]
According to a recent survey
the average American believe
they can survive for 16 days
in the wilderness,
adding, "Wait,
what's the Wi-Fi password?
Today is World Redhead Day
but then the sun came out
and they had to cancel.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new report,
poison control centers
in the U.S. experienced
a significant increase
in marijuana-related calls
between 2017 and 2019,
and they always started
the same way.
"Hello? What's the emergency?"
"Hello? Who is this?"
"Man, you called me."
And that was a monologue.